we're used to thinking of bird nests as
something woven from twigs and grass
perched in trees or hidden somewhere on
the ground but birds in the megapod
family have a different strategy these
bigfooted birds build enormous Mounds
that can be up to five meters tall and
weigh as much as seven tons the birds
use Leaf litter dirt sand and whatever
else is in their environment and as the
materials Decay like in a compost bin it
produces heat these birds tend to these
Mounds for months and when the females
lay their clutch the eggs have a
built-in source of heating which means
no one has to sit on the nest what's
more the chicks that hatch are much more
developed than most other bird species
they dig themselves out from the mound
and within an hour they can already fly
all of this means a lot less work for
the parents